you know I could really just show you
one thing to completely sum up my
thoughts on Alien Resurrection enjoy did
not hit her it's not true it's bullshit
I did not hit her I did not oh hi mark
how do you spell anything
[Music]
well guys we have come to alien
resurrection which was directed by the
man who later made Amelie who the hell
knows what happened with this movie
probably a lot of studio interference
and a lot of people who were just really
not capable of making a film I guess and
they decided to do whatever the hell
they wanted and this is what we got I
hate this movie
I hate Alien Resurrection this is an
abomination this film has barely a
single redeeming quality in it
there isn't a there really is nothing
there's there's nothing really to talk
about you could talk about the xenomorph
creatures yes in Alien Resurrection they
decide to create a clone of Ripley this
isn't really the real Ripley because if
you haven't seen alien 3 spoilers she
dies so we have a clone of Ripley
because I guess they want to use her as
a host to create more alien creatures
because of course man really wants
xenomorphs
because you know why not why do they
want to clone Ripley anyway why is she
the host why do they have to have this
Warrant Officer who was magically a
lieutenant in alien 3 despite having her
license revoked in aliens somehow she
got to be like a lieutenant during the
cryo sleep period between aliens and
alien 3 I guess and now she's a calling
this movie was written by Joss Whedon by
the way
I don't know what happened with this
film and Whedon himself has expressed
extreme dissatisfaction in the film he
stated his script was more fun and
light-hearted but the director made
everyone be more serious and these two
tones don't match up and that's you know
I guess that's an okay excuse but to me
an alien film shouldn't be fun or
light-hearted it should be suspenseful
and terrifying and so the director had
the right idea and trying to make it
more serious but the script wasn't
supposed to be that serious and so the
two just never mesh as a whole it's
really two people doing everything wrong
for what this film should be even the
film score is just so over the top and
incredibly loud and just overbearing
everything about the way the film is
constructed just doesn't work the
dialogue that's being spoken if it was
more of a Firefly serenity Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
Avengers type Whedon esque experience
that could work but the film itself just
doesn't understand how to accomplish
that tone and the script still has quite
a bit of problems namely never really
explaining why Ripley has to be cloned
beyond just a franchise that's being
milked until it dies by a studio which
is the real answer another massive
mistake this movie makes is having the
aliens caged from the opening scene
their pets they're being experimented on
how terrifying this perfect organism
that was so scary an alien aliens is now
just behind some glass and they have a
button that can shoot ice mist at it and
you know how fucking horrible is that it
takes the fear completely out of the
movie they also show the creatures far
too much I love the look of xenomorphs
they're my favorite alien design of all
time but the idea of showing it
constantly constantly over and over
again is the same reason jaws the
revenge among many reasons sucked they
just show the shark all the time like
you have to keep that shit hidden you
can't just always show it on frame
Ridley Scott and James Cameron
understood that let's talk about
Sigourney Weaver in this movie who is
Anne
actress that I really love I think she's
fantastic and just about all the alien
movies even alien 3 in this film she's
like this really over sexualized person
that just goes around touching everybody
and staring in each other's eyes looking
like she wants to fuck literally every
character in this film including the
genome work so who do I have to fuck to
get off this boat but really everyone's
on this level Ron Perlman who I usually
add or one of my favorite character
actors of all time is insanely over the
top in this movie why known a writer is
awful there's also a character in this
movie named Christie who has a hilarious
scene where he bounces bullets off of a
ceiling that's where we're at here
people the film also takes about 15
minutes before the plot fully kicks in
and you can forget about all the dumb
mad scientist experimentation bullshit
and the characters are finally running
through the corridors and the aliens are
you know taking them out one by one it's
50 minutes into the movie before
anything really happens that's worth a
damn everything before that is very
awkward sexual tension scenes between
Wynonna writer and Sigourney Weaver a
hilarious basketball scene that has no
purpose in the movie other than to go
look Sigourney Weaver made the shot
backwards this entire film that I'm
telling you every decision they made was
wrong every single one just take the
characters alone they're expendable
movie characters 101 everything that you
shouldn't do with the movie character
here it's just everyone's a quirk it's
like oh there's a guy in the wheelchair
he can't walk and he talks like this and
he's a guy in a wheelchair so that's his
character who are you expecting
sanika Ron Perlman is a really angry guy
who's angry the one guy can bounce
bullets off walls they're all just a
quirk they have nothing interesting
about them nothing literally nothing the
movie was really bad before but the last
15 minutes are absolute insanity there
is nothing in the entire alien universe
and holds up the last 15 minutes of
alien resurrection when when
we get sucked into this is whatever the
fuck drought was it's just in there I
don't know what's happening
why is nobody to me
Oh
[Applause]
that entire sequence I actually have no
words I don't know what to say guys
let's just talk about the fucking
newborn oh my god the design for the
newborn this thing looks like a deformed
penis with eyeballs I don't I have no
idea what they were thinking this thing
is so fucking stupid looking I yeah it's
so fuckin no I hate it I hate the
newborn I hate it guys I really do I
fucking hate it it's so stupid but hey
at least it has like an amazing death
that's really gross
and over-the-top like pretty much
everything in this movie I mean for
fuck's sake every decision I keep saying
this but it's true every decision in
Alien Resurrection was wrong this movie
is an abomination I hate it it is
definitely the worst in the official
alien for films without a doubt oh my
god oh but hey at least next I get to
watch and review alien versus Predator
my future's looking up oh fuck
guys thank you so much as always for
watching this review I appreciate it and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]